another news is emerged that the prince
of wells's charitable fund accepted a
donation reported to be a million pounds
from family members of osama bin laden
in 2013.
news of the seven-figure donation was
first reported in the sunday times but
clarence house has denied that prince
charles was personally involved
well joining me now is our correspondent
sadia chowdhury and sadia clarence howes
denying that prince charles was
personally involved but the reality is
questions and eyebrows will be raised
about judgment and whether his charity
should be associated with bin laden's
family
yeah it is that isn't it it's the name
bin laden which for many people will
automatically take it back to osama bin
laden but i have to start by saying that
this has nothing to do with osama bin
laden the bin laden family in saudi
arabia is actually very well known it's
well known for
having businesses in the construction
industry it's a very wealthy family it
also has several political ties to
members of the royal family there
but there will be questions as you say
about prince charles's association and
this
coming from reports in the sunday times
today that prince charles had a private
meeting with backer bin laden
the um the man who deposited that money
into the
into the fund that this meeting took
place in 2013
at clarence house that
prince charles agreed to the donation
despite objections from his advisors
and the fund these are all reports uh
from the sunday times and they say that
even after the payment was made some of
prince charles's advisors
expressed um what they think was a
payment that was not going to be in
anyone's uh good best interest and that
they had pleaded with him to return the
money uh now we've had responses from
clarence house
and the charity i'll read out to you
what those responses are they're very
similar the first one from the prince of
wales charitable foundation fund which
says the donation from
bin laden in 2013 was carefully
considered by pwcf trustees at the time
due diligence was conducted with
information sought from a wide range of
sources including government the
decision to accept the donation was
taken wholly by the trustees
any attempt to suggest otherwise is
misleading and inaccurate and a very
similar response from clarence house now
this one says the prince of wales's
charitable fund has assured us that
thorough due diligence was undertaken in
accepting this donation the decision to
accept was taken by the charities
trustees alone and any attempt to
characterize it otherwise is false and
of course there is no indication that
any of these payments were illegal or
improper in any way but it does as you
say raise questions about that
association and it comes especially it
comes because it comes after reports
last month that the prince of wales had
accepted large sums of cash sometimes
stuffed into carrier bags
from a former qatari prime minister
sheikh hamad bin jassin bin jaber athani
and at the time clarence house told us
that there was nothing improper about
that that the money was taken and
deposited into deposited into a bank
in proper ways but also in february the
metropolitan police launched an
investigation
into an alleged cash for honors scandal
after the prince of wales and a close
friend of his were reported to them and
again clarence house defended the prince
of wales saying that he had no knowledge
of that alleged scandal